[Música]
é possível viver daquilo que faz sentido
para você
a maioria das pessoas o trabalho
ele tem grande valor então o que
queremos ser
ou nos tornar acaba sendo muito
importante afinal de contas nós queremos
evitar aquele famoso sentimento de tempo
perdido
só que esse sentimento de termos perdido
há muito tempo atrás ele chegou na minha
casa
ele chegou pra mim e chegou pro meu
marido também ele foi tão forte que ele
chacoalhou muitas estruturas que
pareciam firmes na nossa vida até então
e aí a nossa formação o nosso trabalho e
os nossos objetivos
eles nunca nos pareceram tão
conflitantes mas nós não conseguimos
entender o que estava faltando
porque nós vivemos bem tínhamos uma boa
casa bons empregos uma filha linda e
mesmo com uma vida regrada e um pouco
corrida nós conseguimos ser pequenos
prazeres como cultivar uma pequena horta
cozinhar apreciar vinhos a vida parecia
ter feito mas então por que aquele
sentimento naquela altura da vida
parece clichê mas não era uma questão de
resultados e autonomia ou de liberdade
faltava uma conexão com um sentimento
genuíno de realização de sentir os
nossos valores pessoais sendo alinhados
com as atividades que nós exercemos
nós precisávamos urgentemente reconhecer
esse sentimento de insatisfação mas a
gente sabia que era um sentimento que
leva tempo e também que era um processo
totalmente individual
aí o tempo passou quando a gente se
sentiu à vontade para conversar sobre
isso
finalmente saiu
eu quero ser agricultor e cozinheiro
eu quero plantar os ingredientes e
depois transformá los em pratos no nosso
restaurante
eu também quero ser a agricultora
só que eu quero plantar uvas e quero
aprender a fazer vinho
nós rimos por horas de nós mesmos e de
como tudo aquilo parecia louco leviano
sabe aquela coisa de realidade e versos
expectativa então a realidade é que uma
coisa era cozinhar em casa ter uma
hortinha para consumo próprio e beber
vinho
outra coisa é não ser dessa área e
tentar fazer disso a sua principal fonte
de renda
então só que depois dessa conversa
algo mudou dentro da gente depois que
você descobre o início do caminho que
faz sentido pra você não consegue dar
meia volta e aí
agora nós tínhamos novos projetos de
vida
nós iríamos viver da terra de forma
sustentável
plantando ingredientes para um pequeno
restaurante uvas para fazer vinho tudo
orgânico muito autoral preservando
conhecimentos e técnicas ancestrais
pois bem só que quando a gente está
pensando em mudar de área uma das
primeiras coisas que a gente faz não é
pesquisar
a gente procura entender um pouco do
histórico do cenário atual e também como
são as tendências como está o mercado
neste momento
e foi isso que a gente fez só que
pesquisando nós chegamos a um cenário
nada animador na época porque há dez
anos atrás
o número de produtores orgânicos no
brasil inteiro
segundo o ministério da agricultura era
de pouco mais de 5 mil
isso representava menos de 1% e no nosso
estado no rio grande do sul o número de
famílias produtoras era descer
de mil mesma situação
na mesma época vários veículos de
comunicação
noticiava que o brasil era um dos países
que mais consumia agrotóxicos no mundo
o perfil das vinícolas e do pólo
vitivinícola da região é o seguinte
agora falando de produtores de uva em
específico o número de produtores cabiam
aqui nessas duas mãos eo vinho a forma
de se fazer o vinho já não era assim mas
tão artesanal
o perfil dos restaurantes da região é de
comida típica regional ou familiar
não existia nada de gastronomia autoral
mas então será que deveria realmente
mercado para as nossas ideias
a gente não sabia mas chegou um momento
que a gente cansou dos números
nós cansamos de olhar para as promessas
que as estatísticas nos fazem para o bem
ou para o mal e passamos a olhar o lado
apaixonante do nosso projeto
quero que realmente dava sentido para
tudo e aí
contrariando todos os manuais de
empreendedorismo em pouco mais de dois
meses
nós vendemos tudo que tínhamos pegamos a
nossa família
nós mudamos de cidade e depois daquele
momento nós éramos dois empregados como
sorri muito bom com muita vontade
eu não vou mentir para vocês não foi um
processo fácil ea gente nunca viu tantas
frases eu avisei
e vocês são loucos mas não importava
porque as palavras de ordem elas eram
doação e resiliência
o combinado foi que maria de se manter
ia trabalhando na área dele por mais um
tempo para que a gente tivesse pelo
menos uma renda fixa e eu procurar
estudar
nesse tempo a gente tentar ia ter o
máximo de contato com agricultores
o mundo do vinho e como a própria
agricultura
pois bem foi isso que a gente fez
só que nesse caminho de aprendizado
nós descobrimos uma coisa que ninguém
conta para os empreendedores e os
sonhadores que os números eles são
feitos de pessoas que os números eles
são essencialmente humanos e que a gente
não podia olhar friamente para aqueles
números sem se apropriassem se aprofunda
e entender quem eram os atores daquelas
estatísticas e foi isso que a gente fez
nós permitimos conviver com os atores
dessa estatística
convivendo com agricultores muitos deles
sequer letrados
nós nunca aprendemos tanto sobre o
trabalho e sobre pessoas
nós passamos a não olhar os nossos
projetos somente como um negócio mas a
ter um olhar mais responsável e
responsável com as gerações futuras com
a nossa família com os nossos clientes
com o nosso planeta mas principalmente
com a nossa cultura alimentar
a gente aprendeu a viver e trabalhar de
forma sazonal e é dar valor e entender
que é muito importante conhecer os
ciclos naturais das coisas
plantar colher e se alimentar comprar
sazonal
isso teve um impacto muito grande muito
positivo na nossa forma de consumo
porque a gente passa a entender a cadeia
e entendendo a cadeia
a gente viu que os para as relações
humanas elas permeavam 100% dos
processos que moviam aquela cadeia e aí
ficou óbvio pra gente que nós
precisávamos com os nossos atos e
impactar positivamente todas as pessoas
e que isso não precisava necessariamente
trazer benefícios para a gente ou para o
nosso negócio
a gente estava falando de pessoas e
pessoas elas se conectam com aquilo que
ele gera conexões genuínas
simples assim elas se conectam e se
engajem nós somos humanos e essas
conexões elas precisam existir e
precisam ser reais
mas é incrível e se convive com
agricultores é que a gente acabou
descobrindo uma grande rede de pessoas
movidas por paixão e por grandes valores
e aí já não importava mais se eram
muitos os que eram poucos
a sensação que a gente tinha é que eles
estavam em todos os lugares e que sempre
haveria apoio e foi nesse tipo de
ambiente que os nossos negócios e eles
cresceram e venceram
então respondendo todas aquelas
inquietações lado início sim é possível
viver da terra é possível ver bem de
forma sustentável e produzindo alimentos
e insumos na sua propriedade
baixando curso deixando tudo palpável e
sustentável do ponto de vista econômico
sim também é possível produzir sem
utilizar agrotóxicos produzir bem e com
qualidade em pequenas médias e grandes
propriedades
mas aí não é um dado meu quem fala isso
os relatórios da onu da fao e das
próprias certificadora de orgânicos no
brasil
no brasil e no mundo e sim também é
possível fazer um vinho muito mais do
que orgânico fazer um vinho natural
sendo que o único ingrediente do início
ao fim é a uva como se fazia há muitos e
muitos anos atrás
e essa é uma experiência que pode te
fazendo no brasil em outros três países
e por último sim também é possível ter
um restaurante economicamente viável
somente com ingredientes orgânicos e
sazonais
sem nem mesmo ter formação em
gastronomia e nosso restaurante ele já
tem
em seu quarto ano hoje nós vivemos e
formamos uma cadeia virtuosa com foco na
partilha no convívio nas relações
humanas na responsabilidade social e
ambiental
mas principalmente no resgate de valores
simples e reais nos parece a forma mais
saudável rentável e promissora de
negócio entender o que faz sentido para
a gente leva tempo
diria que cada caminhão um tempo mas se
eu pudesse dar um pitaco sobre a forma
de como você encontrar o seu caminho
eu diria que essa é uma receita que você
deve fazer em um ambiente que você sinta
que tem apoio a ele disse hone um pouco
de sinceridade consigo mesmo uma pitada
de loucura
coloque tudo isso em um ambiente onde
você sinta que os valores possam ser
nutridas e aí
aproveite cada segundo do crescimento
para se transformar e pra evoluir
e vocês o que vocês estão plantando hoje
faz sentido pra vocês
ou tudo se resume em números obrigada
[Aplausos]